president biden says despite the attacks
the u.s mission will go on until
tuesday's deadline for withdrawal ed
o'keefe is at the white house where the
president spoke to americans about the
bombings ed good morning good morning
vlad the president says he takes
responsibility for what's transpired in
recent days and while there's no word
yet on how the u.s will respond the
president made clear
the u.s will retaliate
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay president biden vowing
to retaliate for the brutal attack in
kabul we will not be deterred by
terrorists
we will not let them stop our mission we
will continue the evacuation and while
some republicans want mr biden to expand
the mission you need to retake bagram
and probably retake other airports as
well the president said his military
advisors unanimously recommended moving
forward with planning to depart by
august 31st despite the likelihood of
more attacks we thought this would
happen sooner or later it's tragic that
it happened today it's tragic there was
this much loss of life the president his
top advisers and military commanders
have been warning for days of potential
attacks by isis k the afghan affiliate
of isis and the state department warned
americans early thursday stay away from
the airport because of security threats
outside the gates
then just hours later explosions left
dozens dead as the president was
convening a meeting at the white house
about ongoing evacuations in afghanistan
what does today's attack
say about the us's ability to keep the
terrorist threat in check
once the u.s pulls off military forces
out of afghanistan isis's ability to
target individuals who are on the ground
in afghanistan is very different from
isis's ability to attack the united
states and attack the homeland and we
will maintain and continue over the
horizon capacity with presence and
partnership with
countries in the region to ensure that
they don't uh develop that ability
saki and other aids here at the white
house agree that it was the darkest day
yet of the biden presidency 1a described
it to me as a quote tough and emotional
day and it's important to point out that
despite the violence the mission
continues the white house telling us
this morning another 12
500 people were evacuated out of
afghanistan yesterday even amid the
violence scale all right ed thank you
very much let